What's up guys, we're Pongfinity!
As some ofyou have seen,
we have launched our own table tennis racket
The Pongfinity Sensei
Which is a five-star complete racket.
Today we'll be comparing it to the cheapest one star racket
we could find.
Let's see what the difference is!
Let's put the spin to the test,
do someghost serves.
Start off with the one dollar racket.
You can get at least some spin with thatone.
Let's try the Pongfinity Sensei!
The ball comes back much faster
when hit with the five star racket
so there's a lot more spin in theball.
Okay I'll try to receive the spinniest possible serve that Otto can do
and I'll start with the Pongfinity racket.
Ready Emil?
I'm ready!
And I actually aimed like there!
It's impossible!
Now let's try the one star racket.
Around the net!
Not bad!
Okay okay.
It almost like eliminates the spin so that's goodwith this.
One star racket wins this challenge.
There's actually quite good control for it,
I meanyou can't get that much spin
but it's got feeling.
You can get better curve on the fivestar one,
but you can do it with both.
Let's try out the world's fastestserve with the one star racket.
Surprisingly good!
That would havebeen fast.
Hard to get the spin on it.
That was okay.
Well you can do it with thisone.
But i think we can get it faster with a five star racket.
Let's try it!
Oh yeah!
A lot better.
We can do faster!
Yeah it was a lot better with this one
because you need the grip to get the speed.
Now let's see how it compares in gameplay.
It's a good racket!
Let's try out the one star racket.
It's impossible to hit like quality top spins with this.
Allright let's take a target shotbattle.
First one to knock down the cups, wins.
Oh yeah yeah yeah this is much better!
Oh come back!
That's my favorite one!
Well! 2-1.
3-2!
Well I guess that's 20% better!
Maybe thetarget shot isn't the best measure for control,
but that was fun anyway!
At least a fun experiment!
Let's try a few blocks with the one star racket.
Now it should be a loteasier with the 5 star racket.
Feels so much easier with this one.
Yeah, anything goes!
Let's test some chops!
Surprisingly good chops!
It was a lot harderhitting from Emil's five star chops,
than the one star chops,
because theywere a lot lower and a lot spinnier.
Yeah I'll play some rallies against Miikka
with the one star racket.
See how it goes!
I have to lift the block like high in the air.
He found the block!
Oh nice one!
Yeah the biggest difference isthe block.
Good for counter top spins!
Nice!
So all in all there was a cleardifference between the two rackets,
especially in the gameplay.
If you're a beginner or intermediate,
the Pongfinity Sensei is the perfect choice for you.
So go and get yours from pongfinity.store
Until next time!